all right it's one of the main street
destroyed Trump media's favorite tactics
all to prevent you from getting the
whole story now it's called bias of
omission and today it was on full
display now despite the bombshell
revelations in the Grassley Graham memo
and some pretty damning text messages
from FBI officials lovers Lisa Paige and
Peter struck while the mainstream media
is utterly silent it was a reaction
founder Managing Partner skybridge
capital I'm sorry Anthony I'm not Bill
Maher you're not on a liberal show
tonight alright the Republicans
attacking me Shauna wasn't liberals
that's the crazy that's actually true
you taking from all comers right yeah
and the author of the smear how shady
political operatives and fake news
controls what you see what you think and
how you vote the anchor of full measure
cheryl atkinson is back with us all
right Anthony to me I think Joe de
genève is right and I've been saying it
this is the biggest corruption scandal
municipal attacks it is so people makes
Watergate look look like stealing a
Snickers the problem with it you're
calling you that now but we still got
another ten layers to drill into and rip
off more skin and so once you get really
really deep Shawn
it's absolutely uncontrollable and so
what's gonna happen now they're gonna
make a pincer movement you should read
the manifesto the best-selling book by
cheryl atkinson she'll describe how
they're gonna do to everybody they're
gonna flatten up everybody dehumanize
them they're gonna try to criminalize
the process of finding out the criminals
and it's a nightmare for the american
people but I'm glad you're exposing it
John you're doing a big service a
patriot service and you're protecting
the president and will honestly won the
election despite all of this nonsense
that was happening in the politicization
of these agencies in many ways Cheryl
you who have been a victim of all of
this it was almost a year ago on this
program we broke the story right here
with Sarah Carter and John Solomon who
have done phenomenal work about how yeah
they got a FISA warrant against Donald
Trump Donald Trump tweets out that oh
they wiretap me and the media went crazy
turns out everything and much
or we've been on literally on peeling
layers of an onion here with real facts
and information the media's doll of the
story about Russia Trump collusion with
zero evidence for a year and they by
omission don't cover these stories why
well just to amend one thing I don't
know that they had a FISA warrant
directly on Donald Trump I don't I
haven't seen evidence what they did they
made a page in the Trump right they may
have used warrantless techniques there's
all kinds of ways I was told even before
a Donald Trump announced for office that
Intel officials and I was told this by
insiders have sometimes been using bad
information to bring to the FISA Court
to wrap up other people that are the
true targets that they can't get a
warrant against but to wrap them up in
incidental targeting different ways
without may be a direct warrant know
what happened a general Flynn based on
what we know and that what happened to
poor general flow of course yeah I mean
I think from what we know in news
reporting and what we've learned since
then is that they under the auspices of
listening to a Russian official the US
and the Ambassador from Russia to the
United States they then accidentally
captured somebody who may have been
allegedly their true target and some of
the things will lead them to mister the
bottom line is you've got one
presidential candidate that pays for a
phony Russian dossier
none of it's verified and then and she's
also a Christopher still being fed from
Clinton's own associate then they don't
tell a FISA judge the facts of who
bought and paid for this phony dossier
that's unverified and then it's used to
get a FISA warrant and you're right
about incidental or masking and leaking
raw intelligence and the media for the
most part there's been a blackout isn't
that true
I think there has largely been a lack of
curiosity and a lack of accurate and
thorough reporting on one side of this
issue there's been plenty representing
one viewpoint but very little on the
other side except to the extent that it
debunks and I think that part of the
reason for that is there is a much
bigger scandal under the surface and
some people know this which is in my
view not why not that they were going
after President Trump perhaps during the
campaign but why the
has unlike what they thought would
happen if Jeb Bush were elected or
Hillary Clinton there are some inside
the intelligence community who have been
there for more than one administration
who feared that Donald Trump could bring
in people who would peel back the layers
and see the allegedly improper and
illegal surveillance techniques they've
implemented for a long time so each
state D'Antoni's care emoji deep state
yes but I mean Mike my question of the
American people is how much longer are
we going to tolerate this my question is
also to every one of us out there that
see this happening how do we deal with
these people Shawn because Cheryl myself
and you all know how ruthless they are
how diabolical they are and they'll stop
at anything to stop honest people from
uncovering them well you well Anthony
exactly what Chuck Schumer said they'll
get you six ways in Sunday what this guy
new CNN say Martha win yeah exactly that
monster on that was saying that we're
around for a hundred plus years and
you're around for thirteen months this
is sort of nonsense the American people
have to understand that their government
is there to serve them we are not here
to serve the people that work in the
government they are our servants and
they need to be held accountable for the
nonsense that's going on right now last
word cheryl atkinson well i think
there's much more to come minutes we
should be looking at the big picture not
necessarily all the minutia that
distracts us alright guys thank you both
Looch good to see you welcome back my
brother we appreciate you coming on
Cheryl good to see